what a spotlight on 21 year old rookie
left-hander adrian morehound a
two-and-two record in his
first real season in the big leagues had
a taste last year
and three ground ball outs
it's dustin may to make the start for
the la dodgers tonight 23 year old
right-hander from nearby justin texas
machado sends the ball out to center
field
bellinger measuring it off nothing comes
to the one-out walk second and third
nobody out now for cody bellinger who
was one of the heroes for sure in last
night's dodger triumphs
and the padres get the out there
muncie's able to score but cronenworth
cutting down the middleman
and perhaps
stemming the tide on what could have
been an even bigger moment
peterson's rung up
[Applause]
taylor swings and misses two big
strikeouts for the rookie southpaw
strand of pair and the pods are in
business with runners in the quarters
moreland on the first pitch chops into
muncie
and is able to at least get the out on
the hitter with fam advancing well here
you go eerily similar
second inning base is loaded
a fifth plate appearance coming with the
bases loaded and calerick has just
walked in a run
and that's how the padres get on the
board in game three
oh and two to the veteran left-handed
hitting catcher
back to calerik
to the plate they get the out there
chopper tough play for seeger throwing
across the body not in time and her run
scores grisham's got some of the best
speed on the roster and san diego has
taken their first lead of the night
and a swing and a miss gets aureus out
of the jam look where manny machado is
playing as opposed to
the speed at second one-two to seeger is
sent back up the middle a diving stopped
by tate's throw from his knees gets away
from hosmer and betzel score
uh what looked like a highlight play
waiting to happen
turns into a run-scoring play for los
angeles
and it's a 2-2 ball game a 28-year-old
southbound matt strom will be the first
one to appear he'll try to get out of a
spot with nobody out to run in and a man
at second base facing the meat of the
dodger order
justin turner takes the first pitch into
left field
seeger takes the turn at third
and the dodgers go back out on top by a
run and that's a baseball that justin
turner might want to put in the trophy
case back home his 64th post-season hit
yeah
he's very aware he wants that one he's
past steve garvey
for a new dodger post season franchise
record so jace tingler will choose aj
pollock now with runners at first and
second and two gun
oh one to pollux sent down to left field
that's gonna get down and score another
run here's turner bellinger to third
four to two l.a
3-2 pitch and peterson lines it into the
opposite field bellager
[Applause]
[Music]
six to two dodgers
here's will smith now he's doubled and
struck out tonight the double his first
hit of the postseason snapping an 0 for
11.
there's a second
that's good enough to bring in bets and
make it 7-2 los angeles throw to third
is not in time to try to get seeger
sharply hit great play
[Music]
wow
that looked like that ball was ticketed
for right field what a fine play by the
rookie second baseman
that sends a drive out to right that one
carrying myers back to the track deepest
part of the ballpark and will's able to
make the catch but pollock comes in to
score and it's eight to two los angeles
it's funny how baseball goes with the
like if you give up a three-run homer
here it's almost like a rally kill right
yeah
oh he called the ball
so there's wow
a gift for san diego the [ __ ] brings
machado into score hosmer to third
and it's an 8-3 ball game
no dodger has ever had a five-hit post
season game
smith with an opportunity
smith into the opposite field
and he has set a dodger post season
record
a two-run double and a five-hit game for
will smith tonight
and that's a fair ball two more will
come in to score
bellinger on his way around second
wow
with a two-run triple
an outstanding series
and that'll do it and the los angeles
dodgers have another date in the
national league championship series
a 12-3 game three victory finishes off a
three-game sweep of san diego